et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
françois di mailhiot président de
l'institut de recherche asie un centre
bonsoir jean françois di mailhiot avec
vous on va tenter
voilà soit d'être rassurés au contraire
inquiéter peut-être encore plus sur les
conséquences économiques du coronavirus
alors lancé des oeufs et pas franchement
rassurante le coronavirus mais
l'économie mondiale en danger elle va
brutalement freiné l'économie mondiale
où la croissance ne devrait pas dépasser
2 4% selon l' ocde est ce que vous
partagez ce constat assez alarmiste
c'est difficile de passer derrière l'
ocde en termes de pronostic
il faut simplement rappeler ce que c'est
qu'une année normale ou une année
moyenne en termes de croissance mondiale
c'est 3%
on tombe pas de 4 ou 5 % à 2,4 on passe
si pronostic est avérée de 3% certaines
années 3,1 cette année 2,9 à peut-être
2,4 alors c'est pas sans signification
effectivement c'est un chiffre important
qui est pas surprenant si vous prenez un
pays comme la chine qui représente 15%
de l'économie mondiale en termes de pipe
cette année la chine aura fait zéro ou
premier trimestre probablement sur une
année qui était prévu à faire cinq
ennemis ou 6 % de croissance sur l'année
donc soit on un rattrapage et un rebond
d'une économie comme l'économie chinoise
et les économies émergentes vont
probablement rebondir
les économies plus traditionnels ont une
élasticité moins grande
c'est à dire qu'elle absorbe le choc
avec plus de temps mais elle remonte
aussi avec plus de lenteur
quelles seraient les conséquences
concrètes notamment en france puisque
alors ça a été ça a été effectivement
chiffrer le chiffre était été rappelés
la france encore une fois selon cette
prévision n'entreraient pas en récession
mais surtout ce qui se passe c'est un
phénomène assez rare c'est à dire que
souvent une récession s'est créé par un
ralentissement de la demande c'est à
dire que le consommateur n'est plus là
et là on a un effet qui va falloir peser
de façon très fine
in entre la difficulté de satisfaire la
demande par la réfection de l'offre
puisque on le voit les chaînes de
production en chine sont maintenant
coupé ou en tout cas partiellement
coupés du reste du monde donc le
ralentissement va venir d'abord de
l'offre ensuite dans certains secteurs
la demande ralentit mais dans d'autres
secteurs
sa rage en tir à plus tard la confiance
étant le facteur principal de ce
ralentissement
donc on a des facteurs assez atypique
jusqu'ici dans les dernières crises
qu'on a traversé il faut rappeler que
l'action des institutions
internationales
que ce soit en 2008 1 pour la crise qui
était venu des états-unis ou en 2011
la propagation finalement de la crise
américaine en europe on a eu des
institutions qui ont été très réactives
et qui ont évité le pire
en 2008 on était clairement au bord du
gouffre il faut le rappeler en 2011 2012
on avait un ralentissement très fort
avec des outils nouveaux on a réussi à
éviter
effectivement ces grandes catastrophes
la question c'est quel outil nouveau
va-t-on trouver pour faire l'équilibré
entre ce risque de crise de l'offre
il utilise ce risque de crise de la
demande justement question peut-être de
deux novices mais est-ce qu'on peut
reproduire le même schéma qu'en 2008 les
institutions comme la bce la fed peuvent
reproduire pour tenter de corriger
objectivement un des facteurs
d'inquiétude c'est naturellement qu'il y
avait en 2008 encore un très grand
consensus international
il faut rappeler que le g20 c'est à dire
ce groupe qui intègre à la fois des pays
développés et puis des pays émergents
qui a intégré la chine
ce g20 il est né de la crise de 2008 on
a évolué progressivement et
principalement aujourd'hui vers une
sorte de fracturation du monde
économique
sinon du monde diplomatique donc ça
c'est déjà une première difficulté
et puis la deuxième à la guerre par
exemple 30
la facturation louis ce risque de
fracturation du monde qu'on voit un
petit peu partout et puis l'autre
difficulté c'est que les ssii
traditionnelles qu'on a utilisé c'était
des outils de relaxation de la création
monétaire
c'est encore possible on peut toujours
imprimer plus de mener en satan il ya un
consensus de 100%
actuellement sur le prochain mouvement
de la réserve fédérale américaine qui
baisserait ses taux de 0,5 pour
pourcentage point de pourcentage à 50
points de base
c'est une arme mais il faut probablement
d'autres armes aussi comme celle dont a
parlé bruno le maire l'étalement des
détaxes l'étalement de la tva par
exemple pour les entreprises de façon à
alléger la trésorerie des entreprises
qui seraient engorgé par cette crise de
la demande
vous parlez de récession qui selon ses
dernières prévisions de l'oscd
épargnerait la france en tout cas mais
n'épargnerait pas nécessairement
l'italie ou l'allemagne pourquoi ces
deux pays sont plus en danger que la
halle en allemagne
elle a une exposition majeure hannachi
d'ores et déjà donc l'allemagne
on peut dire est d'une certaine façon en
danger puisque contrairement aux autres
pays européens et n'a pas creusé ce
déficit commercial colossal vis-à-vis de
la chine
elle vend beaucoup à la chine la chine
s'est arrêté d'acheter pratiquement le
15 janvier cette année
donc l'allemagne frappé par cela
l'italie n'a pas encore retrouvé ses
grands équilibres du fait des
alternances politiques du fait de la
relative instabilité politique et puis
du fait aussi du prix que l'europe lui
fait payer de la crise migratoire c'est
à dire que la litanie bien souvent les
européens en disant vous savez c'est
nous qui portons le fardeau de la crise
migratoire depuis le changement de
formule qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
années
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'inquiétude
la part des grands actionnaires mais
aussi des petits porteurs des français
qui aurait pris quelques actions ici ou
là quelle conduite à tenir c'est
compliqué parce que faut peut-être pas
céder à la panique vous nous donnez donc
voilà il faut voir la bourse
on s'est beaucoup focalisé sur la bourse
si vous voulez c'est un indicateur à la
fois avancé de ralentissement mais aussi
de reprise c'est un accélérateur de
sentiments donc la bourse va sur-réagir
systématiquement demain lorsqu'on a vu
ce matin à l'ouverture des bourses
asiatiques qui était rassuré dès que
vous avez un signal positif les bourses
vont rebondir
donc par définition quand on va en
bourse il faut savoir que on est là pour
le moyen terme ou moins et certainement
pas pour faire ce qu'on appelle de
l'infra des trading quand on n'est pas
un professionnel alors bruxelles un
niveau l'armé utilisé tous les outils
nécessaires pour protéger l'économie
alors quelle est la marge de manoeuvre
finalement de bruxelles aujourd'hui et
quels sont ces outils effectivement les
outils de bruxelles c'est déjà la parole
on a on a un commissaire thierry breton
qui est un industriel de formation qui a
piloté une très grande entreprise
française avec un succès extraordinaire
mais le ministère de bruxelles
aujourd'hui sachant que bruxelles ça
n'est pas la bce ça n'est pas la banque
centrale européenne qui francfort qui
coopèrent naturellement avec les avec
les équipes de beaussais le ministère de
bruxelles
c'est avant tout un ministère de la
parole c'est à dire bien nous avons un
certain nombre de questions tout régler
ensemble nous ajustons nos politiques
mais nous n'avons pas de politique
fiscale unifiée en europe et donc
bruxelles ne peut pas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire appuyé sur ce levier
donc c'est un indicateur de confiance
est un indicateur qui lie à un pilote
dans l'avion
au delà de ça c'est surtout la bce qui
va être l'acteur principal
alors vous thierry breton à ce même
série breton qui a chiffré les pertes 1
milliards de manque à gagner par mois
pour le secteur du tourisme on en
parlait aussi dans notre sujet c'est
extrêmement inquiétant
pourquoi alors si ça c'est la wii le
secteur du tourisme secteur le sict le
secteur hôtelier les transports comme on
le voit avec l'annulation d'un certain
nombre de lignes régulières par pas mal
de compagnie aérienne
y compris en asie sont des effets à très
court terme
avec probablement un effet de rebond dès
que ça repartira un effet de confiance
aussi qu'il sera difficile à
reconstruire mais naturellement les
premiers secteurs touchés
ce sont les secteurs du transport et du
tourisme et donc les pays qui sont très
dépendants
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de la france
effectivement la france ne fait pas que
recevoir des touristes qui lie à notre
continent et aussi des touristes qui
traversent la france dans les 90
millions de touristes qui viennent en
france chaque année il y en a qui sont
en europe dont qui resteront des
touristes de traversant la france mais
pour le reste effectivement ceux qui
viennent de loin vont s'absenter pendant
quelques temps la même ocde on avait
commencé par ça on termine par sa
affirmé qu'en cas débiner vie plus
durable et bien là croissance serait
carrément divisé par deux sur les
prévisions de l'oscd eux quelles
seraient les conséquences pour
l'économie en général et pour notre pays
en particulier
alors déjà là les prémices qui font dire
si l'épidémie durer plus longtemps
bon c'est certainement très conservateur
c'est de notre côté envisager des
hypothèses qui sont entre les mains des
épidémiologistes crois qu'il faut
d'abord écouter ce que disent les
épidémiologistes ainsi non pas une voix
une voix unique qu'il qu'ils se
manifestent
vous avez aussi la croissance qui crée
dans deux secteurs
vous avez aussi des relocalisations qui
vont qui vont arriver et si la crise se
prolonge
les décisions de relocalisation pourront
avoir leurs effets et puis vous avez des
secteurs où on parle du secteur
pharmaceutique qui certes est très
dépendant de la chine mais qui
malheureusement du satin à 120 profiter
de la crise les ventes en ligne et
secteurs de l'économie électronique vont
bénéficier ça donc vous avez aussi des
rééquilibrages le transport est en train
d'augmenter ses prix puisqu'on a eu une
raréfaction des transports maritimes et
donc les prix du fret se sont remis à
augmenter alors qu'il était en
dépression depuis plusieurs années
est-ce que c'est peut-être l'occasion
d'envisager un autre système on sait que
notre système est souvent extrêmement
économique est souvent très très
critiqué le capitalisme est ce que ces
finales
l'opportunité de revoir un petit peu sa
copie notamment la dépendance à la chine
certainement c'est effectivement une
situation qui peut permettre cela
ensuite il faut tenir compte de la
brièveté ou de la longueur de la mémoire
des principaux acteurs les acteurs
industriels certainement ont une mémoire
à plus long terme ils font des plans à
moyen terme par les industries soit
lourde ou pas du côté des politiques
c'est plus compliqué parce que très
souvent on agit dans le court terme ont
réagi et on est dans l'action très
rapide donc il est possible aussi qu'au
bout de quelques temps comme ça s'est
passé en 2011 ou 2012
on est oublié qu'on avait traversé une
grande crise il faut aussi le souhaitait
d'une certaine façon que tout cela soit
derrière nous aussi vite que possible
merci en tout cas jean françois di
milieu d'avoir été avec moi merci pour
votre analyse